ある日雪を土屋太鳳に似てますよねふたり
でも言えばいいってもんじゃないんです
こんにちははじめ社長ですと言うけど皆
さんバーあの経験あるとわからないと思う
んですけど俺が多々あるし俺もよく使って
いる気がします信じてはいけないことだと
いうものをご存知でしょうか姉ちゃんなん
かねえことしますね例えばなんですけども
あのたまにあちょっと一瞬貼っていただい
てもいいでしょうか
[音楽]
お待たせいたしましたも5分たってたら
一瞬じゃないんだよね言葉では正しいと
思って言ってても全然ウソやんというか
その言葉は信じてはいけないって結構ある
と思うんですよ一緒になったらもうこれ
ぐらいだと思うんですよこれが一緒なん
ですけどまだ一緒になってもらっていい
って言われ2分また垂れた乳で2分は一瞬
買ってるとそれは刹那的な時間ではないと
一緒じゃないと思うよええ
うん
僕もよく使いますそういうやつですねそう
いうタイプの言葉です私はだが経験上とか
ちょっと独断と偏見で選ばせていただき
ました絶対に信じてはいけない言葉ある
あるをちょっと山とか皆さんに紹介したい
と思いますのでぜひ皆さんこの言葉使われ
た時は信じてはいけないなと思って参考に
してみてはいかがでしょうかでは1
神軽い軽い
20を
[音楽]
voodoo よ
voodoo
んもう
[音楽]
20分
を
んだった
日
info
6なぁ
まず
ちょっと寝ないように起きとくわ俺小笹
沸かせば音が出るわけないだろうがハゲが
高速とかマジでバックアップが欲張っちゃ
ピースかおねがいしますんよ
00分
あった
持っていた
しそしてめっちゃ辛いやつや
いやそうかな俺無理そのかなさが切り無理
くんまじやばい
まあカーを
はい
うん
そんなからな味を食べてみ
いやー食える可能ねちょマジ
よりいけるかな行ける行けるか女から
くらいよくにんしておりますん
[音楽]
お前
ハイあの頭大丈夫だよ
ん
おっ
着替えましたはい
[音楽]
あ
を脚本をニャでしょ
えっ本当に似合ってますかねこれがすごい
200万です言ってますはいすごい
ぴったりで言う最近恋の前にはやってる
感じですかねそうですね
ているところで理由
えっまあそうなぜかですね
いやだ褒められたらちょっとうれしいです
ねカッチャがすごい似合ってますあれって
なんてこれじゃあ会議電話ある日も
ありがとうございます
20分
[音楽]
まずマラソン大会よとなり
ハズレあ一緒にゴールしようないやっ発車
いっ
ええええええ大卒後るよ
car
うん
ん
[音楽]
20分
おっ
あーりえあうんので横へちょーっと
沿ってみよう
ぶー
[音楽]
ぶーっ
入ってったなーって
めっちゃくれよ
まつ号ああっウォッチうわぁ
なります
おっ
ぷっ
明日合格発表だ
お前らはよくやってきた
地元一番良いん
[音楽]
せ税
ても僕
向かっている自信がないんです
なーに言ってんだ大丈夫だいな
絶対合格してるから
お前ようで頑張っ級じゃないか自信持って
行ってもらい
そうですよねああ
俺頑張りましたのね頑張る絶対大丈夫が
先生の毎日勉強したした俺大丈夫ですよね
絶対落ちちゃってますよね絶対なって言っ
ていますいってワイヤー
[音楽]
さん斉藤なバカ性が変わってるなぁ
れんちょんぱぱ位確定
gooああああああ
[音楽]
持った
4日
よっしゃー
まあ近くよっしゃーはいはいということ
だったでしょうか
ん
じょ主席に乗ってでよく寝るやつ版マジで
いますめっちゃ元気だったろうにと店で
眉間がそれでいいんじゃ奴はいるし世の中
にはそういうですねあの信じてはいけない
言葉いろいろあると思うのでコメント欄で
ぜひ皆さんが信じてはいけない言葉あの
実体験のがありましたらぜひ教えて
くださいそれを基に何か第2弾できたら
いいなと思っているので気が向いたら作ら
せてくださいこの動画が特に好評で
コメント欄が今日はいい感じだったらあの
代リーダーんだせればたします
うっわtlr
[音楽]
んっ
よそ
受かってるよ
もし感やんだ
いや食べますね100円とヤッター
受かってるやんだー
やって払っている
にゃっはー
jr
たあ
ああ白酒テレビジョンです
数できる
健康診断で暖を取っていdice k と
か
知ってるんじゃないの hey
りん家の中なんとする頃
[拍手]